The U.S. National Library of
Medicine presents
"Mercury and Our Health,"
A short film by the
Environmental Health
Student Portal
[Paul] Hi mom, thanks again for the sushi! I'll watch a little
bit of TV while I
am eating, and then
I am going to go do my homework.
[Mom] Ok, but don't
watch it for too long!
[From T.V.]
This is Kate,
from "Food Science
for Consumers."
Today's episode is about
mercury in seafood.
There may be too much mercury in the seafood you are eating.
Watch to find out, and learn how to protect your health!
[Paul] Mercury in seafood? I wonder... Is the sushi seafood?
[Kate] It sure is, but don't be alarmed before you learn more!
[Paul] Mom! The T.V. characters are coming to life again!
[Mom] That's nice, dear.
[Kate] Do you know
what mercury is?
[Paul] No, but it sounds like
it's something bad.
[Kate] Mercury is a
natural metal that's
found in the air,
water and soil.
[Paul] What do you
mean by natural?
[Kate] Natural means it's a
part of the environment,
and is not made by humans.
It also exists in
the Earth's crust.
[Paul] Wait! What do
you mean by crust?
Cool!
[Kate] The crust
is the outermost
rocky layer of the planet.
[Paul] Whoa! Cool! Where are we?
[Kate] We are on the
periodic table of elements.
You see, we can find
mercury on this
table of elements by looking over its chemical symbol.
[Paul] What's the chemical
symbol of mercury?
[Kate] The chemical
symbol of mercury is Hg.
This is how we can find it
on the periodic table.
Remember that we
can find mercury
in the environment
in several forms.
Sometimes, atoms of
mercury exist alone,
not connected
with other elements.
This form of mercury is called metallic, or elemental.
People also call this
kind of mercury "quicksilver"
or "liquid mercury"
because it's
a shiny, silver liquid
that can evaporate
into an invisible gas.
[Paul] Oh, I see.
[Kate] At other times,
atoms of mercury combine with
other elements and create compounds, or chemical mixtures.
We may encounter mercury
in different situations
depending on
what form it is in.
Different forms of mercury also affect our health differently.
[Paul] How can mercury
affect my health?
[Kate] If enough mercury
gets into your body,
it could really make you sick.
[Paul] Oh, I don't
like being sick!
[Kate] Of course you don't!
Luckily, if you live in the U.S., there are not that many
ways for you to have contact
with a lot of mercury.
[Paul] But, what
exactly does mercury do?
[Kate] Well, that depends.
[Paul] Depends on what?
[Kate] Several things!
Like, how much mercury
gets into your body,
the form of mercury
that gets into your body,
how the mercury
gets into your body,
and how long you're
exposed to mercury.
High levels of
mercury in the body
can really hurt
many body systems,
especially the
brain and kidneys.
[Paul] The brain? How
does it hurt the brain?
[Kate] These are
some of the symptoms of
brain damage from
mercury poisoning.
Tremors, or
trembling and shaking, and
not being able to stop.
Walking impairments,
or having difficulty walking.
Speech impairments, or having difficulty forming clear words.
Changes in vision or hearing.
Memory loss.
Loss of appetite,
or not feeling hungry.
Feeling
irritated, and psychosis,
or losing touch with reality, such as seeing or hearing
things that
are not there.
[Paul]
I don't like it.
Can it do this to anyone?
[Kate] Yes, mercury poisoning
could happen to anyone,
but it is especially damaging
to children and unborn babies.
[Paul] But I am a child! Why is it especially bad for children?
[Kate] Because their nervous systems are still developing.
The younger the child
is, the more sensitive
he or she is to mercury.
You are more
sensitive than an adult,
but young
children and babies
are even more
sensitive than you are.
[Paul] But you said that there are not that many ways for me to
have contact with
a lot of mercury.
I guess that's
the good news.
But then you also
said that mercury
is a natural
part of the Earth.
This makes the Earth
a dangerous place!
[Kate] Mercury can only hurt us if we come in contact with it -
touch it, breathe
it, and swallow it.
Mercury in the Earth's
crust is hidden in the rocks.
So, the amount of mercury
that's normally found in the
environment is very,
very small and will not hurt us.
[Paul] That's good to hear.
[Kate] Yes. Unfortunately, people do things that make
mercury come out where we can come in contact with it.
[Paul] What do you
mean, people do things
that make mercury come out?
[Kate] Let me
give you an example.
I mentioned that mercury
is found in many rocks,
including coal.
People burn coal for energy.
Unfortunately, when we burn coal, we release its mercury
into the air
and the environment.
[Paul] Oh, I see.
[Kate] Mercury
also has many properties that
people find useful, so we
use it in commercial products.
[Paul] What kinds of properties?
[Kate] For example,
pure, or elemental,
mercury conducts electricity.
It also combines
with other metals,
into combinations
that have many uses.
Other forms of
mercury kill bacteria.
So, we use mercury
in some commercial products.
[Paul] I am not
sure I like this.
We use
mercury in products?
[Kate] Yes, but
less than we used to.
People have known
about the helpful,
useful characteristics of mercury for a long time.
but the knowledge about
its dangers to human health
is more recent.
In the past, people often
used mercury in medicines,
because of its
bacteria-killing properties.
[Paul] Oh,
that's ironic.
[Kate] But in general,
now that we know that
mercury can
be dangerous,
we look for alternatives
to it whenever we can.
[Paul] So, what
products have mercury?
[Kate] Let me give
you some examples:
Glass thermometers
Electrical switches
Fluorescent light bulbs
Dental fillings
Vaccine preservatives
Some medical equipment
Some batteries
And old paints.
[Paul] Wait! There's
mercury in thermometers?
[Kate] In some
glass thermometers.
Heat makes mercury expand, or grow, and this property of
mercury was used in
mercury-in-glass thermometers.
These thermometers
were used for centuries.
But now that we know that mercury can be dangerous,
they have become rare.
[Paul] I've seen them in pictures, inside books.
[Kate] That's right.
But the thermometer your parents use to take your temperature
probably looks
like this and uses
an electronic
temperature sensor.
[Paul] Did people
get hurt a lot
by all those old
glass thermometers?
[Kate] Remember,
mercury is dangerous to us
only when we touch
it, breathe it, or swallow it.
We cannot touch,
breathe, or swallow
mercury inside a thermometer.
The danger happens
when someone accidentally
breaks the thermometer.
[Paul] Glass things are easy to break! What happened then?
[Kate] Well, the shiny, silver elemental mercury would spill
and collect into silver balls - beautiful, but dangerous.
Someone cleaning up the spill could accidentally touch it.
Look how
dangerous that is!
There was also risk
of breathing it, because
liquid elemental mercury evaporated into invisible gas.
[Paul] What about batteries?
[Kate] For a long time,
companies around the world used
mercury to make
many kinds of batteries.
They did it because mercury prevented the buildup of
hydrogen gas
in batteries, which can
cause the battery
to bulge and leak.
Since the 1980s, the use
of mercury in batteries
in the U.S. has
been going down.
[Paul] What about the
batteries in my TV remote?
Do they have mercury?
[Kate] Most batteries
made in the U.S. today
do not have mercury
in them, with few exceptions.
Your typical AA or AAA batteries
for your remote control
do not have
mercury in them.
[Paul] Oh,
that's good.
But, which
batteries have it then?
[Kate] One of the exceptions
is button cell batteries.
These are very small
batteries that look like
coins or buttons
and are used in
small portable electronic devices, like wrist watches.
[Paul] Oh, my watch
has a battery like that!
Should I get rid of it?
[Kate] Remember, mercury
can only hurt you if you
touch it, breathe
it, or swallow it.
You aren't touching
the mercury, because it's
inside the battery
inside the watch.
[Paul] But you said
dental fillings have mercury!
Those definitely
go inside our bodies.
[Kate] Have you ever
heard of "silver fillings"?
They're called silver
because of their silver color,
but they are actually
an amalgam, or blend
of metallic mercury,
silver, and some other metals.
Very small amounts
of mercury are slowly released
from the
blend over time.
For example, while you chew!
[Paul] See? I knew it!
[Kate] But you have to remember that the amount makes a big
difference in whether
something is dangerous or not.
From what we know right
now, amalgam dental fillings
do not harm people's health.
[Paul] I don't get it. It sounds like a lot of these products
that have mercury in
them keep it hidden
or put in very small amounts.
So, does this mean that we have nothing to worry about?
[Kate] Not really.
Remember, a lot
of the products I mentioned
eventually break
or become useless,
so we'll need to get
rid of them at some point.
[Paul] You mean, throw them in the trash! That's easy!
[Kate] It's not that simple.
[Paul] Ewww! Gross! It stinks!
[Kate] If we
simply dump trash
that has mercury in
it into the environment,
it will go into our soil and water, and build up there.
[Paul] So, what
are we supposed to do
with the mercury
containing products?
We can't keep the
broken stuff forever!
[Kate] We have special ways
to get rid of mercury waste.
Many cities and
towns now have
hazardous household
waste facilities or events,
but many products that
have mercury still end up in
landfills or
incinerators that burn trash.
Which means mercury
is eventually released
into the environment and often ends up in rivers and oceans,
which is really bad.
[Paul] Why is it so bad?
We don't drink water directly from rivers and oceans.
We clean it before it
gets into our faucets.
I learned about that at school.
[Kate] But fish
don't get it cleaned for them.
In the United States,
the most common
way to be exposed to mercury
is by eating fish
or shellfish that have
high levels of mercury.
Come. Let me show you.
Let's take a closer
look at the environment.
[Cheerful, playful music begins]
[Music stops] When
people burn coal for energy,
the mercury in the coal rocks is released into our environment.
See? Look how the mercury is getting into the environment.
Once the mercury
is in the environment,
it eventually gets
into the soil and water.
[Paul] But how exactly
does it get into fish?
[Kate] Let's take a closer
look at the contaminated water.
Once mercury is in
the water, some microorganisms
convert it into a very
toxic form of mercury,
called methylmercury,
which looks like this.
Then the methylmercury gets into fish by going up the food chain
through a process
called biomagnification.
First, some tiny
aquatic plants and animals
absorb the methylmercury
that is in the water.
Fish and other animals
feed on these tiny aquatic
plants and animals,
so the methylmercury
gets passed
on to them.
Next, bigger fish
eat the smaller fish and
absorb the methylmercury,
and so on and so forth.
The higher up
the food chain we go,
the more mercury
a fish accumulates.
[Paul] Yuck! Look at
all that methylmercury
in the tilefish,
sharks, and swordfish!
[Kate] The longer
these fish have been alive,
the more time they've
had to eat other fish -
and the more methylmercury
they have in their bodies.
Bigger, older fish
that eat other fish
usually have the
highest levels of mercury.
[Paul] Is it
bad for people?
[Kate] Well, if people
eat a lot of seafood
that's high in
mercury, this can be bad!
Remember, I've said
before that mercury
is especially bad for
babies and unborn children.
That's why pregnant women have
to be careful about how much
mercury-containing
fish they eat.
[Paul] Oh, no! My sushi!
Are the fish in sushi
high up in
the food chain?
Do they accumulate
a lot of mercury?
Should I stop eating fish?
[Kate] There are many
benefits to eating fish.
Also, your mom used salmon and shrimp to make that sushi.
They usually have
lower levels of mercury.
If you want to learn more about being safe while eating seafood,
click on the links
that are on our page.
[Paul] But how? We're
inside a video - inside a TV!
[Kate] It's ok
to stop the video,
or finish watching
and then come back.
I'm also posting
these links on the webpage
on our video so you
can read more about mercury.
[Paul] Wow, I've
learned a lot today.
[Kate] What
did you learn?
[Paul] I learned that
mercury is a natural metal.
People used to
use it in many products,
but now they use
it less and less.
Most products we use
at home are safe for us.
Still, much mercury
ends up in the water and
accumulates in fish, and that's bad for fish and bad for us.
[Kate] That's right!
[Paul] Is there anything
else I should know?
[Kate] Some cosmetic creams imported from other countries
could have mercury
at levels much higher
than allowed for creams manufactured in the U.S.
Also, some alternative medicine remedies contain mercury,
and some spiritual and
religious traditions
use it in
their practices.
[Paul] That's
interesting.
Where can I learn
more about all this?
I know there's a lot of information on the Internet,
but some things
are difficult to read,and
sometimes I don't
know who to believe!
[Kate] You're absolutely right!
We need good,
reliable information
that was written for
someone your age.
This video is part of the National Library of Medicine's
Environmental
Health Student Portal.
The portal has
a section on the
effects of mercury
on human health.
You can also learn there
about other chemicals in the
environment and about environmental health.
[Paul] Wow, I'll definitely
check them out. Thank you!
[Kate] You're very welcome!
Now, let's get you back home!
[Cat Meowing]
[Paul] Mom! Hurry!
There's a TV character
in our living room!
[Mom] Be there in a second!
Where is this TV character?
[Paul] Mom - she was just here!
[Mom] Sure she was!
Just finish up your sushi!
This short film was
brought to you by the
Environmental Health
Student Portal
of the Division of
Specialized Information Services
at the U.S. National
Library of Medicine.
Visit us online at
these great websites!